award-winning musician john batiste is
shaking things up in the music video
for his new song i need you
this is his second single for his highly
anticipated album we
are mati says he created the blueprint
for the album in just
six days in his dressing room at the
late show with stephen colbert
he is the band leader and musical
director of the show performing with his
band stay human
every weeknight john baptiste joins us
now
good morning john jb i see you you had
some
moves man i
didn't know you got to get it in tell me
i used i used to dance when i was a kid
when i was
nine years old my grandmother she would
say due to james brown
and i'm just giving it to the public you
are giving it up and you are like
uncovering a whole new new style here
tell us where it's coming from
and and why it's so needed
well you know the world has been crying
out after 2020
and we've been crying out to be human to
be heard
and fun is a part of that fun is
catharsis fun is
release and in the video i'm tapping
into so much of our history you got the
lindy hop
dance yeah you got the music that you
would hear
lil richard or somebody playing in the
chitlin circuit
all put into a pop song that's what i
wanted to do just have some fun
you call it like a warm hug and you know
the song
the video the muse the dancing
is so incredible uh you you say it took
six days just to write it
that's right you know sometimes when the
spirit hits you you gotta just go with
it
and in six days we wrote the entire
blueprint for the upcoming album we are
but then you know over nine months i
meticulously crafted the album
and it really was a great process for me
because i got to bring in so many of my
friends you know
my mentors mavis staples is on the
record quincy jones contributed to the
record
zadie smith the incredible author who
sings on the record
it was just a real labor of love and
the art just was flowing in those six
days it it was really
unstoppable jonas anthony mavis staples
is a goddess it's great that she's on
this record that's a great lineup you
got there
um i what you were anthony
how you doing you've been you've been
you've been banned leader for
for steven now for for a while but
you've said that you didn't really feel
like a bandleader
still until you organized some musical
marches for black lives matter
what what happened there for you
there's always a time in an artist's
life and in a person's life when you
come into your own and your vision of
yourself
becomes much more clarified and
everything that i've been doing from the
time that i was a kid at juilliard
17 playing in the subways doing love
rides doing procession
processionals i felt like it was made
for the moment that was last summer
which is
a time where we needed to bring people
together in a time where we needed
to have the art pointing the doorway to
humanity
the truth of who we are which is that
we're all more alike than we are
different
so um if i was going to be about it that
was the time to get out there and do it
and
and i'm going to keep doing it you'll
see me out there again
uh john it's tony decouple the anchor at
this table who knows nothing about music
and cannot play a lick and i have a
question on that
subject uh when you play when you
perform
you take such evident joy in the act
itself it's on your face it's in your
body
can you put into words in a peachy
fashion for a morning show
what exactly it feels like for you to
play music
to me music is a spiritual practice is
something that has been passed down
from the ancestors of all of humanity
as something we use to come together
whether it's for rituals
whether it's for celebration whether
it's for some form of worship
whatever it is social gatherings music
is always that fabric that
ties us together and i feel when i'm
playing i'm a conduit
for the whole of humanity and that's
what makes me so happy i feel that
i'm never alone we can't let this end
right now without talking about
seoul that's that disney movie that has
gotten rave reviews
and you are like the essence i mean it's
almost like your life story here
what was it like to see that on the big
screen
i cried it was amazing to have written
music
for the score and to see my hands and my
essence animated in the main character
was something that i never imagined when
i was a kid
watching pixar watching toy story you
know the way that music has been such a
part of their films
i really was moved beyond words how did
they get the hand movements down that
that's you
playing in pixar vision
right right right they had they had they
had gopro cameras all types of
fancy cameras around when i was playing
in the studio
and through pixar magic i guess they
figured out a way to translate those
videos into animation
um i'm not sure how they did it but i'm
glad they did it yeah
we are too giant beautiful movie
beautiful album and it's a i love
the definition of playing music for you
as being a conduit for humanity that is
a gorgeous way to describe it
you knock that one out of the park yes
stay human it's all about that
john batiste manola boo thank you so
much
[Laughter]
thank you john this album we are out
comes out in march
and uh wait did i say that right we are
not wait
we are there we go fire it out you can
watch him on the late show with stephen
colbert weeknights right here
on cbs